Çeviri: HİKMET NACAROĞLU
Gözden geçirme: Sessenol Projesi II
Dondum sandınız, değil mi?
Hayatı yavaşlat derken
aslında bundan söz etmiyoruz.
Öncelikle tanımayanlara kendimi tanıtayım.
Ben gerçek adında Tolga Cavit Güner,
sahne adıyla,
yani tanınan ismiyle Zeo Jaweed.
Tolga Cavit Güner mesleğinden dolayı
zaman aşımına uğramış.
Zeo Jaweed ise sahne ismim,
zaten burada da bir karışıklık olmuş,
bana iki tane kimlik vermişler,
gayet keyifli görünüyor.
Şimdi işin aslı; benim size
çok uzun konuşmalar yapabilecek kadar
akademisyen bir yönüm yok.
Ben hali hazırda
bir rapçiyim en nihayetinde.
Ama bir de şöyle bir durum var,
hepinizin kafasında aynı soru işareti var:
Bir rapçinin konuşması
ne kadar yavaş olabilir?
(Kahkaha)
Bugün burada gerçekleşecek
olanların tamamı bir delil.
Aslına bakarsan mesele benim
ne kadar hızlı konuştuğumda da değil,
bana kalırsa problem beni yavaş
dinlemen ve bu yerinde bir deyim.
Olsun, böyle gayet iyi.
Bazen kafa karıştırıp düşündürmek gerekir.
Mesela bu hızlı hayat akışı içerisinde
kendi eksenimiz dışında
olup bitenlere bir göz gezdirelim,
çünkü yaşadığımız bu gezegene
bir meteor düşmesini dileyebilirim.
Kendi çocuğuna bile tecavüz eden bir baba
ve her yanımda patlıyorsa bomba,
işkenceye uğrayıp katlediliyorsa
ağzı olup dili olmayan canlılara,
kan ağlıyorsa Orta Doğu
ve sessiz kalınıyorsa buna,
zaten kendi sonumuzu
getiriyoruz nasıl olsa.
Bu hızlı hayat akışını yavaşlatacak
başka bir müzik dalı yok.
Sokaktakilerin kimisi aç, kimisi tok.
Magazin programlarının yayınladığı
yırtmaç haberlerinin başlığı şok,
kültür sorularının manken cevaplarında
yalnız olanlar sadece fok yetmiyor.
Ne kadar hızlı olsan da bu dünya
yuvarlak ve başladığın yerde
bulursun kendini durakla.
Kibrin ebediyse
ebedi kin getirir ama
ilk virajda barış var.
Savaşlar olsun istemezsen
biraz hayatı yavaşlat.
Teşekkürler.
Zeo Jaweed
(Alkışlar)